je voudrais dire gilles et raymond parce
qu'il ya plein de gens qui réagit sur
twitter qui s'y est passé
gilles également alors je vous raconte
tout hier il ya eu voilà et envoya une
petite robe louis après l'émission
pendant l'émission il ya eu une
embrouille après l'émission s'est tous
réunis en loge alors là c'était le
conseil de fade away
j'ai pris un visage grave
ah oui très grave j'ai convoqué tout le
monde et j'écoutais les versions de
chacun parce que moi je n'étais pas tout
à fait au courant de la faire ou parce
qu'en fait ils s'étaient embrouillés en
loge et comme je suis le seul à dire au
revoir au public les autres partis chez
moi je dis toute la vérité sonnera la
foulée benjamin s'ébroue pas ouais merci
benji voilà la vérité les autres sont
trop pressés apparemment ils font
d'autres émissions non mais voilà donc
les chais donc je n'étais pas au courant
de tout et heureusement ça s'est bien
terminé
ce sont pris dans les bras ils se sont
fait un petit bisou sur le flipper parce
qu'il ya un flipper normal je fais
bosser minet et moi j'ai fait le dauphin
non mais voilà les chéris donc je suis
content de vous voir tous les deux ici
et je sais qu'il aura jamais une femme
entre vous voilà oui d'après
symboliquement de tendre la main de
l'amitié
bien sûr
l'action
maintenant
je vais pas porter raymond même si c'est
mon super pote mon rêve mon frérot
combattu pèse maintenant mon chéri et je
vous dirai ils se sont juste serrer la
main à la soirée les connaît on a eu
assez viril ça me fait plaisir de voir
tous les deux c'est mon raymond c'est
juste dire que j'étais touché parce
qu'il ya des trucs quand même qu on a
fait les cons tous les deux mais jérôme
j'ai vu beaucoup de messages qui ont dit
de toi que tu te servent et moi etc etc
moi je veux juste dire ce mec là il a
fait des trucs pour moi que personne n'a
jamais fait dans ma vie même ma famille
ni personne il ya deux personnes il le
sait lui et laurent thibeault je sais
pas si laurent thibault il regarde on en
voit ce qui est alarmant thibault je
salue et quand les gens me disent à
nasser de tonnes et méchant moi je suis
libre ici je suis libre ici je fais ce
que je veux je dis ce que je veux on est
une bande gelé dire on est des camarades
peut avoir des mots mais ça m'a blessé
moi j'aimerais dire aux gens arrêté de
m'envoyer des messages pour me dire
qu'elle n'a cessé un compte vous aurez
l'occasion
non mais attends
[Applaudissements]
sur ce truc rires vous aurez plein
d'occasions de défoncer plus tard mais
sur ce sujet il m'a vu que arrêté parce
que ce qu'il a fait pour moi je sais
c'est énorme et je suis le seul
chauffeur livreur au monde a livré le
matin et amiens à la télé ce soir
donnez moi un exemple n'y a pas dans 13
ans donc je vais juste te dire que voilà
0 je t'aime fort et j'en profite pour
dire que je vais me reposer un petit peu
parce que les livraisons tout ça plus la
télé ça fatigue donc je vais un peu me
reposer je vous jure sur la tête de la
marque c'est vrai j'ai besoin de repos
alors notre raymond bosse beaucoup parce
qu'il serait avec tous les amis et bien
sûr il fait toujours partie de l'équipe
de touche pas à mon pote et il sera dans
touche pas à mon poste dès la semaine
prochaine
mais rien n'arrive à se reposer là
jusqu'à voilà la clé les quatre
prochains jours et il sera de retour
c'est vrai mais c'est déjà bien pour les
horaires connaissons mais sachez qu'il
n'ya aucun problème entre eux raymond et
moi ben je voulais dire notre raymond
avant tout c'est un super pote on se
connaît depuis des années et on peut
tout se dire
c'est ça est donc à l'antenne c'est vrai
créneau et moi je me permets de même de
dire des trucs à raymond jeu
ce que je dis moi aux autres parce que
je le connais depuis des années c'est
comme si je parlais un pote dans voilà
chez moi voilà on a vu ce risque est ce
que tu fais moi je viens j'ai pas le bac
je suis haïtien pas avoir le bal jeudi
des conneries des fois à l'antenne c'est
vrai
2 bon voyage et rivière détroit où
j'étais parfois je dis des conneries
parce que je trouve pas bien des maux
équipe français risquent à la personne
et peut-être que tu autre personne et
c'est ça qui est bien alors moi je veux
dire elle a besoin de tout le monde la
télé je vais te dis en vérité mon chéri
est excellent dans l'émission on a
besoin de toi dans touche pas à mon
poste et je peux te dire tu es un
personnage exceptionnel et moi j'aime
les gens en vrai et c'est plaisant
[Applaudissements]